let's get started with the afternoon
session and the first arc will be
Michael caster Jana talking about
preparation of Gib States thanks it's a
pleasure to be here so today I'll talk
about how to prepare Gib States
efficiently on a quantum computer as a
matter of fact the talk is very much
about just applications of this new
machineries of approximate Eric
approximate recovery maps to problems in
many body physics it's a good thing that
the program Quentin didn't realize that
otherwise we would have ended up in the
mega-merger talk by a mission woods so
I'll go over local recovery briefly the
first part of the talk and talk about
the two applications of them which is
the efficient evaluation of local
expectation values and the efficient
state preparation or sampling of Gib
States on a quantum computer based on
some physically relevant assumptions so
the motivation for this is should be
quite clear we've seen in a number of
talk already they talks already that it
would be very beneficial to have
efficient Gib samplers for to be able to
simulate for instance strongly
correlated or frustrated materials on a
quantum computer once we actually have a
quantum computer but more more they seem
to be further applications of Gibbs
samplers to problem say of sdp solvers
is Fernando showed and to the problems
of quantum machine learning at least
people claim this but perhaps more
importantly the point of this talk is to
really introduce these these tools of
recovery maps and convince you that
these are really impact this might be
really important tools for the analysis
of many-body systems in particular they
can tell us something about exotic
phases of matter so uncle very quickly /
strong schibetta tivity because we've
already seen it a few times are going to
see it more in the next talk so we all
know and love strong Savannah tivity of
of entropy it can be written concisely
in terms of the conditional mutual
information which is this expression
here we know that it's always positive
and it has all sorts of applications in
quantum information theory but to get an
idea of an immediate application it
might have in many body systems is that
it tells us it gives us sort of more
information about the area law so
there's one of the basic conjectures
about of many-body systems is that the
entanglement scales is the area of a
region rather than as the volume in
terms of mixed States a natural
formulation of the earlier conjecture is
that the mutual information between
region a and its complement is upper
bounded by a constant times the area
around the region and so it one gets if
we have a promise that the strong that
the conditional mutual information is
small you create rings around your
region and you can show that in fact
considering the mutual information
between a and just the first ring of the
first few rings is almost the same as
considering the mutual information
between a and the entire system as long
as the conditional mutual information
between rings is very small and this
comes from some telescopic some argument
furthermore what we know is that if the
conditional mutual information is
strictly 0 then we get the existence of
a recovery map meaning conditional
mutual information between a and C as a
condition on B tells us that upon the
erasure of a you can recover the
information on a just by applying a map
on a B so see remains untouched and of
course it's symmetric so the same holds
for C we know the exact form of this map
it's this pet recovery map we also get
that the state has a canonical form
meaning that's not entangled and there
existed disentangling unitary which only
acts on B which takes you not to this
form but to form which is very similar
now recently some of these results have
been extended to the approximate case
and in particular what has been shown is
that the mutual
additional information is lower bounded
by a term involving the fidelity and the
proximity of row and row where you trace
out region a and recover it with this
rotated pets map and in fact you can
also get an upper bound so these these
relationships are really very tight
unsurprisingly this theory is also
related to the theory of approximate
error correction but I won't be talking
about that right now now beyond this
what I want to argue is that this
conditional mutual information somehow
gives us a partial classification of
many body states of matters or at least
matter at least in the non critical
phases now this is not a complete
classification you shouldn't take it all
too seriously but it is already known
it's called the cameras Lee Clifford or
quantum powers the clifford theorem that
if we have a full rank fixed density
matrix and we have a promise that for
any regions a b and c where a is simply
connected and be shields a from see if
we know that the conditional mutual
information is always 0 and these in
this configuration it tells us that the
full rank density matrix is in fact a
commuting Gibb state meaning Gibbs state
of a commuting Hamiltonian of local
terms and the converse is also true now
something which is not yet fully
established but we also get a partial
extension of this result to the pure
States and in this case it takes the
form of if a pure state satisfies this
condition for any shielded regions then
it's going to be the ground state of a
commuting local Hamiltonian the other
direction is already known this
direction I think hasn't been published
but it's not much of a stretch to show
it but importantly in the approximate
case we're starting to realize that
there that these results actually can be
extended in generalized because in terms
of many-body systems these can't
are pretty pretty stringent haven't
exactly a zero here we're going to see
in the next talk is that under certain
circumstances so in one dimension you
can show that for a full rank state
where the conditional mutual information
is not zero but exponentially small as a
function of the width of B we get that
the Gibb state is a quasi local
Hamiltonian and the converse is also
true this is only been shown in one
dimension so far it likely holds in
higher dimensions we don't know how to
show it and finally we would like to
generalize this equivalence as well and
right now there are absolutely no
results in this direction but note that
one of the directions is just a
generalization of the area law
conjecture so it's plausible that this
holds as well what I'll be talking about
today though is the dynamics so all
these results pertain to statics of
systems so you're given a state and you
asked for properties of the state what
I'd like to talk about is rather the
dynamics so before getting into the
quantum dynamics I want to review what
we know about classical systems so
classical Gib states and the almost a be
all and end all of simulation in terms
of classical Gabe States or Monte Carlo
algorithms and the idea is quite simple
you want to estimate the expectation
value of a local observable but but
weighted by gabes distribution this
gives distribution is a probability
vector that has exponentially many
entries of course you can't even write
this probability vector down so how are
you going to estimate this expectation
value which is a sum over all entries of
the probability vector now the trick is
quite simple in hindsight you construct
the Markov chain that has this Gibb
state as its unique fixed point and you
iterate the Markov chain of the most
famous example of this is a metropolis
algorithm where you start with a random
configuration of spins for instance you
flip a given spin you calculate the
energy before and after your flip if you
decrease the energy you always keep the
new configuration if you've increased
the energy you only keep the new
configuration with a probability which
is proportional to the Gibbs factor and
then
iterate this as many times as it takes
until your system reaches equilibrium
and then that gives you one sample and
you take the sum over a certain number
of samples which is going to be small
but the natural question is when does
your system actually reach equilibrium
and this is an extremely difficult
mathematical problem that was addressed
for instance was mentioned at least in
the in the talk of Elizabeth's coffin of
Elizabeth crossin and surprisingly for
classical spin systems there's an
there's a remarkably tight
characterization of mixing times of the
metropolis algorithm so in fact it's
it's it's a continuous version of the
metropolis algorithm called global
dynamics and this theorem says that if
the classical Gibb States has
exponentially decaying correlations it
then the mixing time of the global
dynamics of the truck so the
continuous-time metropolis algorithm
mixes in time order log n where n is the
number of particles in your systems the
number of spins in your system this in
particular implies that l so the
generator of the semi-group is gapped
but it tells you in fact a lot more
because gapped will only give you an
order n mixing this is remarkable
because you know that for for a critical
phase so say the two-dimensional Ising
model below the critical temperature
you're mixing time is going to be
exponential and L so somehow you you
skip and exponential and you go from
exponential to logarithmic so there's a
double exponential separation between
the two mixing regimes it's extremely
tight it's very general it's independent
of boundary conditions it's largely
independent to the specifics of the
model and of course when we have this
nice mathematical result we'd like to
find a way to generalize it to quantum
systems and this is what we did in a
result presented to Qi Pisa go with
fernanda buntao where we considered a
natural generalization of global
dynamics which coincidentally is
constructed just from a pet recovery map
so there you already see that there is
this the serendipitous occurrence of
recovery in a problem which you might
think is completely unrelated to start
with to make matters more interesting
this semi group seems to be extremely
behaves almost the same as the the
natural dynamics that you would get from
a weak system environment coupling from
quantum optics and so we were able to
prove a partial extension of this result
but somehow as an unsatisfactory partial
extension because it only held for
commuting local Hamiltonian so as soon
as the Hamiltonians are non commuting we
couldn't say anything and our statics
side of the equation somehow is slightly
unnatural so it would be extremely
difficult for instance to to verify it
in an actual experiment so now that we
know that there's actually this
connection with the best recovery map we
can say okay great so you define a new
Louisville Ian so a new generator of
your semi group where you replace the
pets recovery Mac with this new rotated
pet recovery map and likely the
semi-group does converge and has the
right properties but all the proof
breaks down so somehow the rest of the
talk and the results they want to
present our an effort to control this
non commuting gibbs sampler case so
we're going to take a completely
different strategy ok so to set the
setting a bit more precisely we consider
a finite lattice but that will
eventually take to infinity we consider
a Hamiltonian on this lattice which is
hermitian a sum of strictly local
permission operators and we define a
good state on the lattice in fact we
even define a Gib State on some
restriction of the lattice and this is
going to be quite important in the proof
the Gibbs that you're really interested
in is the one that has a full lattice
here but we'll also need to use a
restricted notion of a Gib state so
it'll be important to note that
superscripts refer to the domain to the
support of the hamiltonian whereas
subscripts refer to restrictions or
partial traces so now I'm going to
introduce three different types of
approximations or conditions that we
want to impose on our system the first
is what I call uniform Markov condition
and this is simply saying that the
conditional mutual information between
these concentric regions is small or
more specifically in fact I choose a
subset of the lattice it could be this
region ABC or it could be this region
ABC and then I say for any region a
which is shielded from see in the
previous lattice then the conditional
mutual information has to be small in
particular has to be decaying with L and
it's important to note that this
condition will need this condition to
hold also for non contractible regions
so these three regions are contractible
to a point where as this region is not
contractible to a point something
contractible to a ring especially if you
put this on a torus second condition is
we want our system to satisfy the cave
correlations meaning the covariance
between unobservable and region be an
observable region a should be decaying
as a function of the distance between
the two regions and again we need the
stronger notion where it also has to
hold on on contractible regions so again
now this is decay of covariance as a
function of the gib state only defined
on the region ABC so not defined on the
whole lattice and finally we're going to
need to use a tool developed by our
chairman here which gives us control on
perturbations of Hamiltonian so if we
consider local Hamiltonian on the
lattice h plus a perturbation which is
strictly local then you can always write
it as an observable V times the
unperturbed Hamiltonian times the
hermitian conjugate of the
and these absurd and these operators ov
or quasi local mean you can trunk they
you can truncate them at a distance L
and the norm is going to be
exponentially decaying it has a function
of L so this is an assumption that
always holds for local lattice systems
fights or three approximations uniform
markov which is essentially the markov
condition the conditioner the mark of
condition unconditional mutual
information uniform decay which is
natural of non-critical systems and
local perturbations which always hold
and I know denote the approximations by
epsilon delta and gamma so now the first
result that we get is that if our system
if our lattice system satisfies uniform
clustering so the second of the
conditions then then to estimate local
observable and a it's sufficient to
consider the Hamiltonian only on be
rather than on ABC so the partial trace
over bc of the gib state on ABC is
approximately the same as the gib state
on a be where you trace out region be so
in immediate consequence of this is that
local local operators can be estimated
efficiently meaning you don't need to
consider the entire gibbsite on the
entire system to get a good estimate of
local expectation values the proof is
quite simple you consider Rho X where X
is region a B and C and you compare it
to row a B so this is really the gib
state only defined on a B and they give
state only defined on C and you note
that you can write it as a telescopic
some we're aware these row XJ plus 1 and
Row XJ are the gib state with a
Hamiltonian where you've removed terms
one by one and
terms you've removed or indexed by by J
so you find out that this expression
which is the same as this one can be
upper bounded if you can upper bound
each of the elements but the benefit of
upper bounding each of the elements is
that they only differ at a single point
in the Hamiltonian so it's only a single
Hamiltonian term where they can be
different but then we can naturally use
this perturbation argument where you can
pull out where you can express the
unperturbed Hamiltonian the protocol
Tony enters the unperturbed one with his
operators J and these operators J or
again quasi local so you can truncate
them and commute them through GA which
is only supported on a so that you can
express this local indistinguishability
in terms of the covariance and this is
one was one of our absorptions that the
covariance has to be small now the main
result uses these methods a bit further
so it says that if we have a full rank
state or a good state on the full system
that satisfies uniform clustering and
uniform Markov with errors epsilon and
delta on a d-dimensional lattice then
there exists a sequence of quantum
channels F D plus 1 all the way down to
F 1 such that F acting on any input
state minus the gib state is upper
bounded by a term scaling as a volume
and a sum of all the error terms now the
specificity of these maps is that each
of these maps each of these individual
Maps fd1 to f1 are tensor product of
local maps not completely local maps but
maps that are order L local on the
lattice so it's pretty obvious to see
that if if the error terms decay faster
than L to the D we get a good upper
bound on the convergence of the
algorithm now perhaps more relevantly we
can actually perform this iteratively so
we get say in two dimensions you get
three Maps here
and then you take each individual map
which has order log l which is order log
l local consider that your new lattice
and then reiterate the situation and in
this way you can get strictly you
construct strictly local maps but now
they're going to be log l many of them
it turns out you don't need these errors
to be exponentially small to get this
constant locality they only have to be
polynomial a small and now the proof is
it is actually quite simple when it
comes down to it you cover the ladders
with concentric squares or three
concentric squares now let's just focus
on a single one a minus is going to be
the inner concentric square in a green
one a is going to be the red one and A
plus is going to be the blue one and
then we use or to the two properties
that we assume so Markov condition and
the cave correlations or rather local
indistinguishability to construct a map
that only acts on this blue red and
green region so in particular we
consider we first trace out the red and
green region to obtain row a compliment
but we know that because of the markov
condition there exists a quantum channel
which is local only on the blue ridge
well on the blue red and green region
which recovers tracing out the inside so
this gives us our first map and then
this state is the gib state of the whole
system where we've traced out regions a
minus an a but this is a hard state to
work with instead we'd like to consider
the get state which is restricted to
[Music]
well the good state which is not defined
on a so it's going to be this row AC
minus but this state is going to be
close if you once you've traced out a
it's going to be close to simply tracing
out the complement of a because of local
indistinguishability now when you put
these two maps together you
you obtain that in order to go acting
with with this local map fa on the
lattice which is built by the Gibb state
only defined on the complement of a
minus you can reconstruct the full
lattice so and fa by construction is
going to be a local map this na in front
comes from from taking the union of all
these maps because there are going to be
na different blocks and of course the
the support of these maps is going to be
given by how good your approximation is
the second step of the proof once we've
removed the a- regions we want to remove
intermediate regions between the blocks
that you took out and you do this in
exactly the same manner so we we first
trace out the red and green regions and
apply the modified pet recovery map on
these and then by local
indistinguishability we say that we
could have in fact started with the
region that didn't have support on be so
we get a second map FB by this
construction and now it tells us that if
we're able to construct a get state on
the complement of a minus in b- then
we're able to reconstruct the entire
system so that already seems helpful but
then in the third step you realize that
the complement of a minus and be- is
completely disconnected lattice so these
disconnected bits of the lattice can
just be prepared by projection again by
a local map so what you've what we've
constructed in the end are three local
channels one applied after another that
applied on any initial state will give
us the desired Gib state up to an error
which scales as NC and A&M be where an a
and B and C or the number of regions we
have to apply this this trick to so
moral of the story the entire lattice
can be built from a local circuit of CPT
maps
but now we proved all of this for Gib
States but you might say a lot of the
analysis didn't depend upon the fact
that we had give states so the proof
ingredients required a form of local
indistinguishability which you can
naturally define for ground states of
local hamiltonians for instance it
required a form of uniform arc of
condition which you can also naturally
define for for peer states in particular
ground states of local Antonians but you
also need a local definition of states
but this you obtain exactly when you
consider ground state of local
hamiltonians and turns out by using a
recent result of martin trots and the
incisor you can apply the exact same
proof to injective peps so starting from
the cave correlations and the markov
condition you can you can derive an
algorithm which prepares ground states
of injective pet or injective peps in a
time log n which is exactly the same
scaling which was obtained by yeomen J&C
rock with a completely different method
so this seems to be quite generic and
now it's interesting is there's a
natural connection to the topological
entanglement entropy so if you remember
in the proof I said that we need the
Markov condition and the exponential
decay of correlations condition to hold
on non contractible regions but the top
one of the formulations of the
topological entanglement and should be
specifically that the conditional mutual
information between AC as a function of
B on a non contractible strip is going
to have a fixed topological contribution
so it's not going to be exponentially
decaying so this tells you immediately
that this theorem is not going to hold
for topological systems but this is
exactly consistent with what we expect
because one of our definitions of
topological orders that you cannot
prepare it with a finite depth circuit
so this is very consistent but even more
so we get that if the topological
entanglement entropy is zero and we have
local indistinguishability which by the
way is there is one of the other
definitions of topological order if you
have many ground states of a hamiltonian
then it implies that there exists a
local circuit so it somehow connects in
an interesting way to definitions of
topological order with a third and up
until now this hadn't hadn't really been
known how to go in this direction the
other direction was known incidentally
Kataya presented a similar result in an
unpublished work and a talk a few years
ago so where do we go from here perhaps
the the most exciting thing about this
proof is that it gives us a first it
gives us a road map in fact for proving
an extremely important open problem in
many body physics which is based on some
static properties of a state say if you
have injective peps and you know that
they have exponential decay of
correlations show that the parent
hamiltonian of this state is gapped and
it's our belief that methods similar to
these will lead to a proof of the gap
apparent hamiltonians of peps there's
still some work to be done in terms of
relaxing the assumptions on uniform
decay so this uniform decay assumption
is is a bit stronger than what you'd
like it's certainly a lot stronger than
what you can measure in experiments and
generally this is one of the very first
applications of these ideas of recovery
too many body systems we expect it to be
many many more in particular completing
this classification seems to be an
important problem so thanks
time for some questions
um yeah so you mentioned at the end that
you think similar techniques might allow
you to prove the gap of an injective
peps but in that case I don't see why it
shouldn't matter that it's actually
injective and not like topological like
a yo-yo argument in the other case of
why your methods don't work when it's
not injective made sense but to prove
the gap you think you could also extend
that when it's not injective like
something I actually didn't hear I can't
I didn't hear the question you're asking
why injectivity is important yeah for
your sort of conjecture that you could
use this to prove the gap of an
objective peps why would that not work
because they like to G injective well
the direct proof would cause a problem
obviously because you'd be preparing a
state with a log depth circuit and we
know that topological models are
typically not injective and they also
don't have a log depth circuit so it's a
very first step one well first step yet
to start with we'd like to show this for
injected peps if it if we can show that
and of course it would be nice to
generalize the g injective pets because
we also expect topological models to be
gapped but it really seems to cause a
lot more complications ok so you just
think it's the method that might not
work but yeah
any other questions I'd like to ask one
quick question you mentioned that it
probably couldn't be efficiently
prepared if there's a nonzero
topological entanglement entropy we know
examples where it can't be but could you
bound the amount of nonlocality needed
by the amount of topological
entanglement entropy but I haven't
thought about that it seems to be pretty
black and white you really need these
exponential tails so I think it answers
probably not but it but I certainly
haven't thought about it very much all
right well if there's no more questions
let's thank the speaker again
[Applause]